now we also have a lot of company for  you stopping on the 15 out of the  spaghetti bowl lanes are open  also some slowing northbound of the 95  heading into the spaghetti bowl  shouldn't lose a whole lot of time there  we're watching the roads for you  throughout the rest of our show as well  as cbs this morning alex  all right thanks nate and cbs this  morning begins here at the top of the  hour  and tony decouple is joining us now from  new york with a look ahead good morning  to you tony  hey good morning alex that traffic  report had a lot of references to the  spaghetti bowl what is that  people driving it it's the actual thing  it's where all the highways merge  together here in vegas  it looks like a spaghetti bowl all right  all right i  my uber has not made it through the  spaghetti bowl i just go from the  airport to the casino